die hat er nicht - nach wie vor geht und
keine ausgesehen
ja klar ruhige und jetzt gibt es
natürlich in dieser stress zwischen
soldaten und das ist nichts gewiss
kartoffeln kochen und schwein für front
lieferung dafür soll das ist natürlich
als dass man das heraussuchen und
weitersuchen
ich laufe jetzt sparen ja sicher
[Musik]
dies ist die geschichte der irina von
burg eine frau aus der ukraine
dieser baut 20 jahren im solothurnischen
grenchen lebt längst ist sie
eingebürgert und hat hier ihr glück
gefunden alles perfekt wäre da nicht der
krieg in der alten heimat der wiener
noch den schlaf raubt dies ist die
geschichte einer 38-jährigen die alles
hat und doch ihr leben riskieren will um
soldaten an der front zu helfen
unterwegs in richtung ost ukraine wo die
grenzen zwischen freund und feind längst
verwischt sind warum tut die schweizerin
dass und wie sinnvoll ist ihre hilfe
davon erzählt dieser film
[Musik]
irina zu treffen ist dieser tage so
schwierig wie sich mit einem
geschäftsmann zufrieden nur minus
geschäft sind spenden
hier arbeiten alle zusammen schweizer
afrikaner und ukrainischer hausfrauen
wie die spenden stammen aus dem ganzen
land
[Musik]
die meisten hilfsgüter sind für mütter
und kinder von gefallenen soldaten
bestimmt und für kriegsverletzte diesen
jahres also eben stolz dass ich kann mir
helfen würde helfen bis das gleich
fertig elina sammelt aber nicht nur für
notleidende zivilisten ist ja sehr sehr
wichtig wie erste hilfe für die fronttür
soldaten
[Musik]
es ist schwierig weil ich komme direkt
und sagt ich brauche für soldaten helfen
das heißt wir unterstützen
naja mehr aber es wird nur noch niemand
nachsagen er klagt seit aber wie sie
jetzt auch nie visier zu schauen hier
nein zeit wurden
von einer hilfsorganisation bekommt
elina wolldecken des schweizer militärs
und auch die sind nicht für flüchtlinge
sondern für soldaten gedacht grenzgebiet
um das machen also große mengen würden
sich das ist so aber die waren für irina
von du geboren in den zeiten der
sowjetunion 19 oberlehrer aus klausen
schwester auf dem beruf aber arbeitet
sie nie
es lockt die weite welt oder konkret ein
groß gewachsener bauunternehmer in der
schweiz vermittelt durch eine freundin
die ihren mann wie alonso fand auch
irina heiratet bekommt drei kinder
heute ist sie geschieden es ist juli in
wenigen tagen wie sie mit mir zusammen
in die ukraine reisen
ziel die front row scharf geschossen
wird ein ironischer zufall oder ist es
die propaganda der mutter die gerne zu
sagen pflegt putin greif nicht mit einem
glas
herzlicher als irina im frühling zum
ersten mal an die front vor sagte sie
den kindern nichts davon was sie sagte
sie machen ferien in der ukraine aber
die kasse nach insofern beruhigt heißt
es ist nur photoshop hat nichts tun aber
sie beruhigt
[Musik]
ganz klar nein
zu wenig
das kommt schon eine vielzahl ganz darin
schon oh mein gott warum ein persönlich
behagt mir der gedanke nicht den
hilfskonvoi bis ins kriegsgebiet im
osten zu begleiten
irina fährt vor uns los wie werden sie
im westen der ukraine wieder treffen und
die dinge auf uns zukommen lassen
eine woche später wir sind in einer
industriestadt in der nähe der
polnischen grenze und wir warten auf die
lastwagen mit der hilfe aus der schweiz
sie sind längst im land aber sie stecken
in diesen zollfreilager fest ich
versuche elina zu erreichen keine ahnung
wo sie ist eben hätten sie die einfuhr
papiere bekommen sagen diese männer
sie gehören zum lokalen team von irina
in der ukraine bezahlt man offenbar bis
zu 50% schmiergeld wie ist das bei
diesen spenden
nein diesmal wurde teils mehr geld
verlangt es gibt keine anzeichen von
korruption
alle verstehen dass diese waren für
soldaten und für familien von
kriegsopfern bestimmt sind und dann
kommt auch irina und damit kann unser
rob trade losgehen
wir fahren richtung osten richtung krieg
irland hat sie schon ob man für android
musik spielt sie das gar schon in
westerholz eine ausnahme möglich
es ist nicht ganz ruhig weil der sturm
in den blick schon
und dass mir diese trauer und in jedem
staat geht's einfach fordern
hier hat alles begonnen der marienplatz
die blutige revolution vor anderthalb
jahren
der korrupte präsident janukowitsch
vertrieben
die creme annektiert durch russland der
osten des landes im krieg
motto hey das volk die kriminelle baum
wer aus es meinte die oligarchen die das
land ausgepresst hatten android das
spiel auch die 53 jährige anna saier was
sich seit der weiteren revolution
verändert die kosten für unsere haben
stark zugenommen
für die mobilisierung für den
wiederaufbau in den befreiten gebieten
es ist klar der alltag ist schwieriger
geworden
wir müssen uns in vielen dingen
einschränken es gibt sogar eine
fernsehsendung in der kindern vermittelt
wird wie man eine woche lang auf sachen
die nicht unbedingt nötig sind
verzichten kann
anna verteilt flyer und verdient 80
franken monatlich nicht viel mehr als
den mindestlohn die landeswährung hat
massiv an wert verloren
zwar sind die läden voll aber die
ukraine können sich immer weniger
leisten
früher habe ich das ganze stück wurst
gekauft jetzt nur noch die hälfte
generell kaufe ich 300 gramm statt
früher ein halbes kilo
die lebensmittel die meine familie
besonders gerne ist können wir uns oft
nicht mehr leisten
auch wasser gas und strom seien viel
teurer geworden sagt anna irland ist
faktisch bankrott
es hängt am tropf des internationalen
währungsfonds die hilfsmilliarden aber
fließen in die taschen der regierung die
bevölkerung sehe nichts davon
darum unterstützt die schweizer in ihre
heimat zu ihren helfen gehören auch
freiwillige die in bataillons kämpfen
sie hätten weniger mittel aus das
militär sagt irina mein einwand dass
oligarchen angeben die bataillone zu
finanzieren wird von ihr und ihren
männern bestritten
die meisten dieser kämpfer sind keine
ausgebildeten soldaten sondern
berufsleute wie der rechtsanwalt sergej
markow schenkung
auch er hatte auf dem marienplatz
demonstriert
seit einem jahr kämpft er gegen die
prorussischen separatisten haben sie
noch nicht von der frau
ja ihr habt sicher im fernsehen gesehen
dass ein elektrizitätswerk beschossen
wurde und zwar in unserer stadt den
justy dabei wurden zwei menschen
verletzt
die zwei freiwilligen verbände die irina
von buch und bestürzt sind umstritten
er trägt ein shirt des bataillons das
abzeichen erinnert an das zeichen der
panzerdivision der waffen ss im dritten
reich die sogenannte wolfsanger sieht
sehr ähnlich aus nur das n ist
spiegelverkehrt bitte erklärt schnell
was das ist
europa ist das wichtig das ist ein
nationales symbol der ukraine die
stimmung ist angespannt
in dieser schwierigen zeit will ina
keine kritischen fragen zur ukrainischen
kein verloren
für sie ist klar putin allein ist der
agresso und alles muss getan werden um
ihn zu vertreiben
[Musik]
erst allmählich begreife ich wer die
situation in diesem land hinterfragt
wird von lina verdächtigt von der
propaganda aus russland beeinflusst zu
sein
wir besuchen laut ocha mutter des
siebenjährigen maxime natascha arbeitet
in einer kartonfabrik und seit einem
jahr ist sie witwe ihr mann gestorben im
krieg
[Musik]
können sie mir bitte erzählen was ihrem
mann passiert ist sagte teilt dem jungen
mit dass ich in den osten gehen
ich fragte warum er sagte ich gehe als
freiwilliger das land beschützen und
damit ist dieses gespräch beendet die
abreise des vaters ein schock sein tod
im krieg erst recht und doch so denke
sie habe sich der einsatz jedes mannes
gelohnt
der krieg dauert aber schon über
anderthalb jahre
die russen sind immer noch in der
ukraine erinnert sich das nicht an
deinen mann schmerzt es dich nicht
ja natürlich ich weiß auch nicht was ich
dazu sagen soll
es gab viele andere junge männer die
zusammen mit meinem mann die sind krieg
gegangen sind
die rhinos engagement ist beeindruckend
ob es wohl auch damit zusammenhängt dass
sie in der reichen schweiz lebt
inzwischen hoch so dass die gestorbene
leute
das tut weh
die versorger auszuleihen egal wie viel
schon andere welt die schon 20 jahre in
der schweiz und in anderen welt nicht
immer nur darum dass ihre eltern würden
noch in der ukraine leben sonst aber
verbinde sie nichts mehr mit diesem land
sie kommt mir vor wie eine frau die
zwischen den welten lebt ich frage mich
ob sie jemals in der schweiz angekommen
ist
durch den krieg in der heimat jedenfalls
scheint jetzt ihre ideale rolle gefunden
zu haben
auf helferin zwischen den kulturen
weiter zum nächsten besuch wieder
bringen wir eine torte mit ein zeichen
der höflichkeit in der ukraine
das war teams wie die denker noch am
leben ist grenzt an ein wunder
er war militär arzt von der front beim
kämpfen wird der 42-jährige verwundet er
will zum spital fahren mit seiner
kompanie aber dort kommen sie nie an
erst wird der konvoi beschossen dann
fährt der lkw auf eine mine und
explodiert nur wenige soldaten überleben
drei nächte lang müssen sie in der
führerkabine ausharren
bei minus 20 grad ich bat den
kommandanten nicht einzuschlafen ich
habe gegen den schlaf gekämpft als ich
wieder aufgewacht bin war ich der
einzige überlebende alle meine kumpel
sind erfroren
lina schenkt ihrem kriegshelden
umgerechnet 200 euro das ist doppelt so
viel wie seine monatliche rente aus
kriegsinvaliden im gespräch mit martin
sagt irina auf russisch auch ihr bruder
kämpfe im krieg das lässt mich
aufhorchen
davon hat sie bisher nichts gesagt sie
habe das gehört habe dass sie habe das
gehört woher das heute haben sie das
jetzt belauscht mehr kann ich dazu nicht
sagen nicht will nicht dass man die
morgen töten unterdessen aber ist ihr
bruder von der front zurückgekehrt lina
ist erleichtert jedenfalls ist sie mehr
in diesem konflikt involviert als sie
sagt hätte er noch hände füße morgen
schon wäre er wieder an der front sagt
war dem seine seele sei immer noch im
krieg was für ein krieg denke ich ein
trauriger bruderkrieg ukraine kämpfen
gegen ukraine und gegen russen
dabei haben sie eine gemeinsame
geschichte die bis ins mittelalter
zurückreicht die ukrainische armee
kämpft nicht gegen das russische volk
sie verteidigt irland die russen und wir
sind wirklich brüder
ich habe viele freunde in russland und
es fällt schwer sie zu verlieren
wir kämpfen gegen ein politisches system
ein system das uns von den russen
aufgezwungen wird
der nächste morgen erstaunlich wie
lebendig die längsten zauberten helden
der sowjetzeit noch sind irina bereitet
sich auf einen speziellen tag vor
heute beliefert sie ein weiteres spital
und sie hat gerüchte vernommen dass sie
dort eine auszeichnung bekommen soll
[Musik]
und während spitalbetten aus einem
altersheim in thun entladen werden
staune ich nicht schlecht
[Musik]
mehrere fernsehsender aus der ganzen
region sind da und auch der gouverneur
juli schenk wurde direkt vom präsident
poroschenko ernannt
irina wir möchten sie mit dieser
medaille auszeichnen
sie stellt den kampf gegen den aggressor
aus moskau symbolisch dar
hier steht freiheit für die ukraine oder
tod
das ist ganz klar die leute brauchen wir
fahren ins hauptquartier von irina
soldaten zeit die schweizerin im
frühling an der front war hat sich die
sicherheitslage erheblich verschlechtert
studierte karte erst just die
frontverlauf dem fluss entlang
die situation dort es wirtschaft
geschossen
irina scheint die schlechten nachrichten
stoisch zu ertragen und ich denke an die
strafverfahren die gegen mitglieder von
freiwilligen bataillonen laufen kämpfer
sollen ukrainische bürger die sie für
sympathisanten der russen hielten
festgenommen geschlagen erpresst und
ausgeraubt haben beide seiten machen
sich schlimme situation ist ich sage es
ganz klar eine heute diese nie
gefährlich diese ganze noch mal
anständige leute heimische fertigung und
handel und kämpfe dass putin bedingt
nicht alle hier um meine bataillon also
nicht meine bataillone der bataillone
sind nie gefährlich und wie die hilfe
starrte mich und meine hier technik
halten bis jetzt leben
wir möchten uns bei der schweiz bedanken
dass sie unseren kämpfern hilft
schweizer militär der kann sind
weltberühmt nicht nur die schokolade
nein nicht nur und während sich die
soldaten an den spenden erfreuen habe
ich genug gehört zu haben
ich denke es ist besser für irina und
mich auf das letzte stück unserer reise
an die front zu verzichten
aber ich hoffe ich dem land geht besser
mit dem zieht das wird alles tut wenn es
um das pressen sich somit eine
sicherheit ging hier abgeht aber was
mache ich mir ein urteil an
als bürgerin eines landes das vom krieg
verschont geblieben ist
prinz bleibt der ukraine sie wünschen
dass diese verborgene konflikt gelöst
werden kann
irgendwie
[Musik]